bah oui les pommes et québec fonctionne
la promesse couette aliments préparés au
québec
bonjour mon nom c'est julie je suis
accompagné de mon garçon antoine 10 ans
de réseau d'écoles un jeu mag est
vraiment les épiceries des fois dans les
petites boutiques
au coin de la rue je sais de faire
l'achat le plus local possible
on a commencé à acheter des fruits des
légumes dans les petites fermes
environnantes mais en fait on désire
aller plus loin le cette année contre
lui à acheminer étant donné que je
cuisine plus de 1000 plots par année
donc le fait de venir à l'épicerie de
faire l'exercice d'aller voir où sont
les produits locaux parce que j'aime
encourager les gens du québec
vous allez pas les provenances
d'indiquer sur les viandes rouges
nous avons demandé à trois familles de
faire une épicerie uniquement avec des
produits locaux achetés dans trois
épiceries grandes surfaces en périphérie
de montréal en plein mois de mars-
hommage s'équiper de la cad pour moi
mais moi c'est mes skis proches
mais si notre région en fête puis vesti
proche du québec qui en fait le local
ben moi je dirais un rayon d'environ 25
kilomètres de chez moi mais tout ce qui
est du québec en fait l'eau pour moi
c'est le cas aux états unis
produit du canada troqué sa fonction
familles devaient parcourir toutes les
allées pour identifier des produits qui
répondent à leurs critères d'achat local
en essayant de payer le moins cher
possible huit années 90 il est regardé
tel hymne aux états unis
mexique etats unis
lâchez-moi l'a pas grand chose de ses
albums lutte à magog années 90
nationalités
même en hiver il est assez facile de
trouver des légumes du québec sur les
étals de nos épiceries par revenu québec
chuq savoir les poires peut-être
d'argent aux états unis mais pour les
fruits la disponibilité est tout autre
mexique c'est pas facile les légumes on
a eu beaucoup plus de facilité que les
fruits
voici à quoi ressemble le panis choisi
parmi les légumes d'ici en comparaison
avec celui qui sera constitué de fruits
d'origine locale au prince me pour
l'exercice
nous avons demandé à louviers et emilie
de faire leurs achats de fruits pour la
semaine s'en soucier de la provenance
pour ensuite comparé au panier rempli de
fruits frais locaux à qu'on n'aurait pas
mal complète et nos fruits
donc l'eau seriez-vous prépa maths ou
l'hiver à manger ça plutôt que ça moi
personnellement non parce que je trouve
que si des boules le calme et en même
temps je viens d'apercevoir cueillez pas
vraiment beaucoup de choix dans dans le
local et la variété malheureusement
pollock qui on est une famille qui aime
beaucoup les agrumes
québec ou importé est ce réaliste de
vouloir s'alimenter localement 12 mois
par année selon sylvain charlebois
professeur de politique agroalimentaire
c'est possible la réponse est oui on
peut le faire mais à quel prix
et est ce qu'on est prêt à faire des
compromis c'est c'était essentiellement
ça en hiver l'offre diminue de façon
substantielle pour plusieurs catégories
surtout dans le maraîcher alors il faut
faire des compromis le faire des
compromis aussi sur le prix et sur la
distance qui nous sépare du producteur
du canada au comptoir des viandes le
choix varie beaucoup d'une épicerie à
l'autre on a trouvé facilement du poulet
du canard de l'agneau et des viandes de
gibier est l'hymne à québec
c'est ici agen devant les étiquettes
mais le choix se réduit comme peau de
chagrin dans le port et il est presque
impossible de trouver du boeuf du québec
et avez vous d'autres poissons qui est
du québec et même au québec
belle surprise les poissonneries de
certaines bannières offre une grande
variété de poissons frais et de fruits
de mer d'origine locale a à toutes les
logos son lot ample sfax est parfait le
priant de la cl vraiment pour lui
prayssas qui gagnera il ya du doré du
canada ici on a aussi de l'églefin du
canada il ya quand même beaucoup de
choses même la morue nos familles
auraient pu acheter aussi du saumon
canadien des moules des crevettes 18 hrs
si l'étiquetage sur les provenances des
poissons est assez clair il en est tout
autrement dans plusieurs rayons des
supermarchés a aucun gain de syndiqués
aura ben non c'est un produit des états
unis tout les ingrédients très peu
fournis y compris si par contre tout les
gens se comprendre mais y ait pas
fabriquer six heures c'est trompeur
c'est écrit le petit québec mais
grippaux du québec
même en parcourant toutes les allées il
nous a été impossible de trouver des
produits locaux au rayon des bars
collation déconfiture des céréales des
craquelins de l'huile de canola de la
moutarde ces aliments ne contiennent pas
au moins 85 % d'ingrédients d'ici le
critère pour être étiqueté aliments du
québec à peu près tous les produits
transformés montrent aussi leur haut
niveau
feibel compliqué si je faisais mon nip
ce prix là en tout un été en vérifiant
les étiquettes comme ça en prendrait
trois heures ça a comme pas de bon sens
[Musique]
bien que dix mille cinq cents produits
soient étiquetés aliments du québec
repérer les informations demeurent
souvent un casse tête facile de trouver
des produits laitiers de chine ou à prix
compétitifs
même chose pour les yeux pour le pain
les légumes en conserves culture est
emballé au canada par fuir ce mais il
faudra s'attendre à des écarts de prix
importants pour certains produits dont
l'eau pétillante locales à 1 $ 89 au
lieu d'un dollar pour le produit le
moins cher le porc du québec est à 21
dollars le kilo au lieu de 15 $ pour
celui qui n'affiche pas la provenance
des frais de fer et julie devra payer 2
dollars 50 de plus si elle choisit les
fraises d'ici plutôt que celle du
mexique sont demande aux canadiens de
classer les pertes et malheureusement la
chose locale se classe très rarement aux
premières heures en fait souvent aux
quatrième cinquième risque est le
premier facteur souvent qui reconnut le
au travers le canada
même au québec c'est c'est le prix
ensuite la qualité la variété aussi voir
des facteurs extrêmement important un
peu épuisé nos familles semblent
ressortir de cette expérience lui même
en ayant fait quelques découvertes on a
terminé je trouvais ça comme un peu
difficile sur les étiquettes à trouver
là ce que ce soit des produits va mal
aux combles franchement lyonnais et
certains produits ou à se tourner le
produite le retour d'information qui te
fait douter le passage à la caisse du
supermarché pourrait nous faire
réévaluer nos convictions les plus
profondes
mais lorsque vous avez dans vos sacs
c'est presque 185 dollars c'est cher
pour rappeler que cet exercice s'est
fait en plein hiver que des économies
peuvent être beaucoup plus importante si
on panique
viennent vos achats